[Music]
everybody it's Charlie we got to talk
about Batwoman coming to the arrowverse
now so they just had the CW up front
where they announced what the schedule
is gonna be for all the TV shows what
the new TV shows are going to be and
what you know like really big things
that are hyping up and Stephen Amell was
hyping up Batwoman in Gotham City so
I'll try to explain how they announced
that they're planning on fitting those
into the arrowverse and what she's gonna
be doing which shows she's gonna go on
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos this is all separate from what's
happening in the Titans universe with
the DC streaming service too so like
this is that woman on the CW DC TV shows
they haven't made any announcements
about Titans or the streaming service or
any of the shows that they announce that
are going to be going to that that'll
probably happen later this summer at
Comic Con if you're not familiar with
the Batwoman character at all and you're
confusing her with Batgirl or something
like that
she's Kathy Kane different character
from Barbara Gordon but was also a big
part of Batman bad blood so if you're
big fan of the animated movies you can
watch that and get kind of a sense for
her character it kind of gives you a bit
of an origin story for first tell me why
you're running around Gotham playing
dress-up I'm guessing Nightwing busted
naturally I think he's more than capable
of fooling most people and you're
certainly not gonna pass her Batman
shortstack who the hell are you
easy Robin investigative report on
Batwoman aka Katherine Kane Katie you
know her her father is Colonel Jacob
Kane military intelligence on
Katherine's 12th birthday she and her
twin sister Elizabeth were abducted
along with her mother Gabrielle and held
for ransom
Colonel Cain led a rescue mission that
saved Kate's life but in the attempt
both Gabrielle and Elizabeth were
murdered she would follow in her
father's footsteps enrolling at West
Point but ultimately expelled something
broke inside Kate
two years later Katherine emerged as
Batwoman she's impressive but her
methods make her danger to this city and
to herself it's time for me to decide if
I'm going to take her under my wing
or take her down but the biggest thing
that they changed is gonna be the
schedule so like here you can see it
just like a screencap of it right here
Sunday night is Supergirl Monday night
is now legends of tomorrow and arrow
then Tuesday is the flash and black
lightning which is pretty much what
they've been doing for the second half
of the season within this conversation
they didn't say what the premiere dates
were going to be in how many episodes
some of the newer shows are going to get
like Black Lightning only had 13
episodes legends of tomorrow typically
has fewer episodes per season so I'm
assuming it's gonna be the same thing as
last year but the Batwoman character is
going to debut during the crossover
episode which is also when we'll
probably get to see Gotham City
inside earth ones universe for the first
time now they said she's going to debut
during the crossover so that's why I'm
assuming it's going to be earth one and
it's not gonna be some separate earth
that she travels from it'll be some
crazy explainer it'll just be as simple
as Oliver Queen referencing Bruce Wayne
on arrow this season then then picking
up logically in the wake of that like
okay well you have a Batman now so you
have the other bat family members that
means there's a couple of Robins out
there but they're gonna be mostly on
Titans TV show so I think the idea that
that woman is coming to the arrowverse
means that she's not gonna be in any of
the movies anytime soon and she's
probably not gonna be in the Titans
universe because the only Robin or bad
family people besides Batman that I know
of that are gonna be on Titans this
season are gonna be Dick Grayson because
he'll be the Robin character
transitioning to Nightwing
then the Jason Todd character we haven't
heard about Tim Drake on the Titans TV
show but if I hear any news about that
I'll do a separate video the whole idea
of introducing a character like bat
woman into the arrowverse probably means
that she's going to be a recurring
character on all the shows like she
won't just be on arrow or just be on
flash or just be on Supergirl they
didn't say how many episodes she's gonna
be in but because she's gonna debut
during the crossover event it's gonna be
like this really big thing like when
they introduced the Hawks if you
remember that maybe you don't want to
remember that let's just imagine this is
a better version of what that could have
been they in Vandal Savage were a core
part of the plot so I imagine that
introducing bat woman will make whatever
the story of the crossover is a bat
woman centric story so it'll have
something to do with Gotham City I'm
sure they're gonna have all kinds of
referencing Batman lore but the whole
idea is I think because Gotham is going
to be ending after next season after a
shortened run Gotham was renewed for
another season he's going to become the
Batman character by the end of that but
it's only supposed to get about 13
episodes to wrap its story up so I think
you know just kind of freeing up Gotham
City and Batman characters inside the
other TV shows wherever they be but if
you're wondering which version of Batman
is the Batman on arrow I'm assuming that
he's an older version of the character
that's maybe a little bit older than
Oliver Queen and it's not the young
version of the character because they're
cancelling this they haven't crossed
Gotham over with any of the other TV
shows thus far so I think they're kind
of a cordoning it off in its own little
corner of the DC TV universe because all
the shows are now like back-to-back like
literally they're jamming them on three
nights there's no way that I'm gonna be
able to do videos for every single TV
show but I haven't really been doing
videos for Supergirl so that's not
really an issue and I really only did a
couple black lightning videos but
because now Monday is the legends of
tomorrow and arrow I'll probably have to
pick and choose which show I do videos
for cuz I won't be able to do one at any
given time so we'll just figure that out
when we get closer and I can always
combine stuff if I need to if there's
really big stuff going on because
Constantine is going to be a regular on
legends of tomorrow which is a pretty
big deal so I don't know what they're
gonna be doing at the beginning of arrow
season 7 beyond this teaser that they're
gonna completely fracture the fabric of
the show with the finale like everybody
will be in different positions so I
think we could talk more about that
after the arrow finale which is tonight
my video for that will post Friday
morning there's a whole bunch of
Deadpool that we'll be posting in the
next couple days to make sure you go see
that because I will be posting my Easter
eggs and all that stuff starting this
weekend I know you're asking all kinds
of Batwoman questions I'm just assuming
that she's gonna be about as old as the
other heroes on the other TV shows which
is like around late 20s early 30s if
you're on arrow
Oliver's like a little bit older than
everyone else but just by a couple years
so that's why I think that arrowverse
Batman is just a little bit older than
Oliver Queen he's not like the old man
Batman and he's not the young kid
version of Batman but what'll happen is
is they dropped more promos for the
flash finale so I'll post those
this weekend like I said my arrow finale
video will post tomorrow morning we'll
talk all about season seven and the
schedule changes and how everything's
gonna look but don't worry
Comic Con is still coming up at the end
of July they'll do the same thing they
do every season where they drop all the
trailers so we'll have plenty to talk
about in addition to all the Titans
Young Justice season 3 swamp they like
all the TV shows that they announced for
the DC streaming service so like I said
during my last Young Justice video there
is a rumor the Titans will premiere at
the end of the summer there's a pretty
good chance we will be talking about
Titans episodes before all the CW DC TV
shows come back so we'll just play that
by ear but there's a whole bunch of DC
stuff happening I'll talk about Marvel
TV stuff in the Marvel videos that I do
but agents of shields finale is also
happening this weekend I will be doing a
video for that and talking about next
season because the next season of shield
isn't gonna premiere till after Avengers
4 you kind of see what they're doing
they're like they're waiting till after
the resolution to the finger-snap and
all the people being turned to ash while
you wait for everything click here for
my new flash finale trailer and you can
click here for that brand new infinity
war a turtles scene thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight